[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga Nazis in
the Bundestag for the first time since
World War two that was the dark picture
painted by Germany's foreign minister
this week as he referred to the prospect
that the upcoming election could put the
right-wing AFD party into Parliament and
unless the latest surveys are badly
mistaken the AFD will cross the five
percent threshold needed for
parliamentary representation and
possibly even emerge as Germany's third
strongest party top AFD candidates
insist the party simply voicing
conservative citizens concerns yet at
least one party leader is under
investigation for alleged hate speech
AFD positions are divisive so much so
that that the German Justice Minister
considers part of the election platform
unconstitutional just how dangerous is
the party that calls itself alternative
for Germany are they a real alternative
or a threat those are the questions we
want to talk about on quadriga
and here are my guests it's a pleasure
to welcome Barbara Yuna she's deputy
editor in chief of the German daily
newspaper the toughs and she says in
this upcoming election for the first
time in post-war history right-wing
extremists will be elected to the German
parliament and to me this is a threat
and pleasure to have Malta looming on
the show once again he's an editor for
the daily newspaper the Tagus Spiegel
he says Germany can cope with the AFD
10% right-wing populist s' won't harm
democracy and finally we're very glad to
have you Anson with us he is a Dutch
freelance journalist with a focus on
right-wing populism
he says the exclusion of politically
disenchanted people by established
parties is far more dangerous than the
inclusion of the AFD robber EULA let me
start out by quoting your opening
statement there you say you see this as
a threat would you go so far as foreign
minister Sigma Gabriel when he says that
the election could wind up putting Nazis
in Parliament it was a drastic warning
by our Sigma Gabrielle it was a warning
ten days before the elections so I
understand that it's a political thing
but still you quoted me it's a
right-wing extremists for sure that will
be in a parliament that will be sitting
in the inner I stock yeah and that's a
threat sure
multi living Europe make statements said
that the AFD is no real fundamental
threat but some of its leaders are under
investigation for language that is
possibly incitement to hatred and
division under the german constitution
do you think that a parliamentary
presence of this party would wind up
giving a platform to such thoughts and
possibly lowering the threshold for
hateful rhetoric definitely i would be
more than happy if they wouldn't come
above the five percent threshold it
would not be represented in Parliament I
would be more than happy but if they are
would that being a threat to democracy I
would very much doubt if one or two
persons on the investigation but does
that mean they already are convicted of
violating certain certain things I don't
think so and the investigation means the
judges are investigating if they find
something that is that is forbidden to
say in Germany they should punish them
that's that's how it goes and that's
what the future will be yep Johnson
we're hearing some very vocal bashing of
the AFD from Germany's established
parties would you say that helps or
hurts the afdc chances in the election
well I think it helps the AFD in the
elections because you know the
established parties now actually show
that you know they did the AFD is a
party that's standing outside of the
establishment and the motive for many
voters is to vote for a party that it's
not within the inner circle of the
burnin politics so it doesn't damage the
AVD at all but you know let's take a
look at the AFD s chances for a while
this spring it looked like they almost
might self-destruct and now we're seeing
this sudden upturn in the poll numbers
what's behind that oh that's a change of
the of the public discussion I'm sure
but also it's a it's a question of how
they they campaign because their
campaign is now growing they have quite
a force behind them
and they're spreading like out their
positions I think that's behind it
because that's what we've seen in the in
the US as well that's what we've seen in
France so that's at least that's part
about it I would say the a of these poll
numbers are all the more remarkable
because the party has become
increasingly extreme since its founding
in 2013 originally born as an EU skeptic
party it has reinvented itself as the
voice of anti-immigration anger let's
take a look at the party leadership and
the issues alice Vidal and Alexandre
Gowland
there's something of an odd couple
seventy six-year-old Gowland is head of
a national conservative wing while the
young businesswoman leads the moderate
economic camp the common goal is to take
the AFD into Parliament dear friends we
need Russia as a Christian bulwark
against an Islamic land grab and it's
time that we took a defensive stance -
the ones that our external borders are
standing wide open
since 2015 people from all over the
world have been coming here without
identity papers without us knowing who
they are
this one Ghazi isn't
sure it enough of what we've been
calling climate protection and that
means quitting all the national and
international agreements related to it
the AF DS many phases are they policy or
blatant populism Matt looming policy or
populism and to what degree is this
leadership duo one reason for the recent
upturn in support I don't think it's
it's so much reason I don't think that
these two is Canada I personally think
they could have have a dog and as the
people could elect and they still would
have eight or nine percent so I don't
think Alexander Gowland or are these
vital are very good eloquently speakers
charismatic persons can some kind of
this I doubt that very much it's kind of
a movement anti climate change
first of all anti refugee policy anti
Europe anti all these things and I think
it's it's it's not so relevant who is on
the top anti anti anti but in particular
the overarching theme anti-globalization
that is that is one of these word that
needs to be explained
yes anti-globalization in the sense that
that many things that comes with
globalization liberal cultural
liberalism global point of view not
being so nationalistic they want to go
back to nationalistic policies to
Bismarck kind of policies and so on and
so on so they think many developments
that happened in the past are dar to be
against Europeans and I don't understand
why you say it's not a threat because
all you mentioned is is going backwards
just going backwards beyond or before
the point of policies of friendship of
consensus that they'd build the post-war
era so that's that's a threat to me it's
a threat to the transit transatlantic
relations it's a threat to the EU if we
talk about ten or fifteen percent that
the aft might might become the next
election we have ten or 50 percent
represented for all these things I've
just meant they are 85 percent of
parties that have a
census about Europe about the refugee
policy about climate change in a row but
all these other things and none of these
parties will ever go into a coalition
with these parties like like they did in
other European countries so I I can't
see how this will this will change the
public discourse but it will not change
actual policy yep yes in your opening
statement talked about the exclusion of
many people in the population from
political discourse would you say that
these two candidates are perhaps giving
voice to a resentment against political
correctness of the sort that we see as
from supporters of someone like Donald
Trump yes absolutely and I also don't
agree that it doesn't really matter
which which leader is on the top of its
leading this party I think we've seen
Garland's and we have seen at least
vital being extremely amateur istic
their timing is bad the party is badly
organized when they enter the Bundestag
in this term that also means that their
party is going to learn that this party
that the profile is going to be
strengthened that they have a national
platform and these parties change over
the years I think they had a very stormy
phase behind them and as we've seen with
care builders or with Japan what these
parties are learning in in in the first
few years in Parliament is how to
attract multiple groups in society so it
starts with the more extreme voters
maybe who are really you don't want to
be part of the establishment anymore but
all of a sudden SPD voters Kuna voters
also and more CDU voters they cross the
moral line and think like okay they show
quite some competence in Bundestag I can
support them maybe the next time so the
Thresh the moral threshold is getting
lower let's come back to the
implications of a presence in the
Parliament perhaps a little bit later
but let me ask because you talk about
giving them a platform let me ask Baba
Yaga
what kind of sentiments we might see a
platform being given - we've heard this
week about an email allegedly written
Ms vital in which she voiced pretty
rabid xenophobia and as we mentioned
German prosecutors are investigating mr.
Gowland for statements that they say may
violate Germany's prohibition on
violations of human dignity those
statements called for Germany's
integration minister to be quote unquote
disposed of in Turkey would you say that
this is a level of hate speech that in
fact violates the Constitution I don't
think it why alights the Constitution
perhaps it wire lights the criminal law
but the Constitution we have quite a
good thing of free speech not as as
openness in the u.s. but still it's not
the Constitution for me it's it's two
directions so for one the being elected
to the Bundestag means it's it's a door
open for right-wing extremists to choose
like stream into the Bundestag and then
you have the the other direction
spreading in the other direction so
that's for me the the real bad thing and
then there so the one oldest member of
the 8ft to be elected got back talking
about the Jewish myth of Holocaust he
was quoting an Italian Nazi but still
that's that's the kind of language that
that could violate the Constitution yeah
multi looming would you say that we are
seeing a kind of a watershed in German
history the for the Financial Times
recently wrote that until now the German
experience of the Second World War
Germany's history has inoculated it
against the rise of a racist
anti-semitic right wing has that somehow
dissolved that inoculation I would not
call them Nazis as our foreign minister
designate Gabrielle dear I'm very
careful with all these descriptions
because if you call the AFD politicians
Nazis you say in a sense they are like
Hitler if they are like Hitler
was not so awful as we all think so it
makes a relative ation of our own past
we should be very very careful in using
these terms they are not Nazis they are
voted for a number of reasons I doubt
that it's that anti-semitism is the
first of all from the first of all is
the refugee policy the refugee policy to
be critical against the refugee policy
was not represented in Parliament by
none of the parties that are now into it
so it's the only party that is voicing
skepticism about this refugee policy we
didn't have an open European discussion
in Germany because of our pattern what I
think we have to be good Europeans
because of our bad past as Germans so so
even the discussion about the level that
we have to talk about our dark sides of
our past is I don't like the discussion
but it's it's a legal discussion to to
to to go through neo-nazis in in this
party or they are close to to group so
it's not Nazis in the parliament but
there are in this party and we know it
and that's that's a threat yes let me
ask you Anson because of course you come
from a country that does also have quite
a strong far-right presence in politics
how do you see the AFD and the situation
in Germany in comparison for example to
that and then other ones yeah I think
Germany is relatively late having a
right-wing populist tea party that's
entering Parliament and I think it has
to do with it has to do with more than
just the refugee crisis just with more
than dissatisfaction with the euro this
is a problem that in whole Western
Europe the party systems have in the
last 20 years established parties have
forgotten a large part of the German
folders the disenchanted voters as I
call them on a few main topics that's on
the negative side of the multicultural
society that's the negative effects of
Europeanisation and the discourse about
these topics was not possible every
party especially in the right who wanted
to start this discourse was directly
being framed as being extreme right or
Nazis party and I think that's a that
that includes a big danger because these
people feel
collected by politics for ten twenty
years already and this is their anger
coming out now and the refugee policy of
the refugee crisis was the symbolic
moment for the AFD that people got over
this moral threshold so but to come the
difference with the for instance gate
builders in the Netherlands is that
within the AFD there are definitely
extremist groups the AVD is being
infiltrated by extremist groups with
reai deal i ideologies that you won't
see with gabriel Francis give illness is
very is a it's basically a liberal who
just doesn't want Islam ization in in
the Netherlands and he only talks about
freedom and the strength of realness and
what that's what the AFD is incapable of
doing is including other minorities in
the party so the AFD is very native
istic is actually a little bit about the
white german but he's stronger anti
islam and stronger Islamophobia than the
AFP is i want to delve deeper into the
topics and attractions for AFD
supporters but because you mentioned the
established parties let us take a look
at the leader of one of the established
parties the chancellor herself
campaigning in her own district where
AFD support is on the rise the
chancellor campaigns in her
mecklenburg-vorpommern home region but
gets whistles and boos I think building
Germany's future on whistles will lead
nowhere
the 2017 campaign is different the
German flacks are thinning out surveys
are giving the alternative for Germany
20% and more in mecklenburg-vorpommern
the euro crisis energy reform and the
immigration crisis after she opened the
borders on her own and we say we want to
send Miss America back home Mackel has
won every direct mandate here more and
more voters feel alienated most of all
by Angela Merkel's refugee policies
opens her arms wide and says come in
everyone as I see it letting all these
asylum seekers in it just wasn't well
thought out went all wrong dead Merkel
disregard a widespread fear of
foreigners and give the AFD a boost
barbar younger mecklenburg-vorpommern is
an area that has been through profound
structural change over the last 25 years
basically since the fall of the wall in
many respects it almost resembles a
state like Iowa in the United States
which of course give strong strong
support to Donald Trump so question to
you is this really only about that
fateful decision in 2015 to take in
refugees or is it about deep-seated
structural change in its effects oh it's
absolutely about the the deep-seated
changes that took place there we toured
the whole country the last year for one
year and we we learned really from the
people democracy is not served for free
you have to discuss with them you have
to see what is really a problem in all
those places and not only America I
think most of the established party
didn't look into it
Multi lemming polls seem to show that
many of the AFD supporters are by no
means at the bottom of the economic
pyramid so what's driving the
frustration and the anger let me try to
be to be superbly fair towards the AFD I
mean they warned about a lot of
developments that really took place they
weren't about rising criminality they
weren't about integration problems they
won't about homophobia they weren't
about everything that comes with
refugees and which is a real problem and
it has some it was admitted by the by D
by the old parties just after months
after months after months I don't share
all these concerns I think we can do it
I think we can integrate them and I'm
very optimistic about it but if you have
to be fair to them their feeling is we
were the first who want you and now
you're proving with your policy at
Makkah has changed tremendously in our
policy with closing the borders with
Turkey with the with the Mediterranean
with the or the that no family members
can can come come home and so on it's on
so she switched her own policy under the
influence of everything the AFD World
Health you can see from outside
Germany looks to many people in the
world like Europe's calm and prosperous
island in the middle of a turbulent sea
what do the Dutch make of developments
here
I think the Dutch also think this that's
my job as a journalist here is also to
show people that a lot of things happen
under the surface in Germany a lot of
things you don't really see also not in
and the highest platform like in the
Bundestag we also had of time of course
that German media was largely ignoring
problems with with migrants as we have
seen and with around Cologne so fast
tonight and I think you know many Dutch
people think like well they did the AFD
it's like a copy of off gate vilnius but
i think and the people don't realize
that there is this also this extra mist
extra mist is a stream within this
within this party and that as i see that
that's my job also to explain this to to
the dutch public ok given that stream
let us very briefly come back to our
title and talk about the degree to which
this could be a threat AFD is going to
be represented in Parliament there's no
question about that Barbour Junge to
possible alternatives at least as I see
it one would be that the bloom wears off
once they are in the limelight the other
one would be they get that platform
we've been talking about and it has an
enormous impact on public opinion how do
you see it and they got the platform so
I agree with the extremists we have been
talking about it the platform will make
them rise even I think I don't think
they will rise above let's say 15
percent there was always a certain
amount of of people in Germany who had
right-wing or extremist views and they
were not represented in the party now
they are represented in the party but
the party I can't see why advise I mean
we have we have to deterrence the brexit
and the Trump election in the USA that
works as a deterrent because it shows
where right-wing populism leads us to
this is not an example that if you see
it on TV that many people admire so I
think riping populism isn't on the rise
we saw the election results in France
even in
in Holland and we will see them now in
15% I think 15% is is European humanity
but over the whole line populism and
right-wing populism Europe is still
rising compared to 10 years ago so this
not that the movement has been stopped
that's we have to be careful about this
but they'll also happen when the AFD
enters the Bundestag as you've said
before many of the especially cdu/csu
they copied their policy points and they
also copied their rhetoric and the only
thing the AFD can do is then is further
radicalize in tone for the karela key
lies in their positions we have seen
that with wielders we've seen that also
in other countries so and that's that's
definitely a big threat so we need a
definitely a political alternative in
Bundestag from other parties especially
from the Left parties and in the
Netherlands had never really succeeded
in other countries that never really
succeed that's the big challenge and
Germany can show that they can do it
this time
that essentially poses the question
probably hyuna can the established
parties including the smaller parties
rise to the threat and essentially help
the voters the citizens to see the AFD
for what it is
I said democracy is not served for free
but you can work for it and we should
work sooner and harder then
activists that in the u.s. parliamentary
democracy of course means coalition's
what would you think might be the best
coalition to lead Germany in a
parliament that it will include the far
right the best I don't know what the
outcome will be so for me it's always a
left coalition but that's not realistic
that's the point I would say if there is
a strong left it would help but it's not
strong enough at the moment I think the
Jamaica coalition with the visitor mica
would be the CDU and the FT we have to
explain this Jamaica Jamaica of course
included black yellow and green and
those are the party colors of the
Liberals the greens and the governing
city right now because that would put
the SPD
in the opposition it would be the
strongest opposition party I have I'm a
little bit afraid about the a of D being
the strongest opposition party because
then they have some parliamentary rights
for example to be the first speaker if
the if the government is announcing
something to answer them and so on and
so on there are a number of rights that
come with being the strongest opposition
parties
I think the SPD is the strongest
opposition party can help the the aft
little bit in check
yep you answer yeah well I'm not too
sure I think Jamaica coalition so it's
actually a replacement of the grand
coalition in a certain way what we see
in not only in the Netherlands but in
other European countries as well it is
it are the right parties the right wing
parties I'm not talking about a FDR but
FDP and and see is you see you who are
Chancellor's conservatives and to live
exactly they are actually the most
successful encountering populist parties
because these are the right parties who
better understand that this is not a
struggle about social economic topics
but about social cultural topics and
about security issues about integration
issues and right-wing parties understand
it better so if you want to keep the AFD
a small party a right coalition would be
better thank you very much to all of you
for being with us today and thanks to
all of you for tuning in hope to see you
soon
[Music]
you